how close are we to the edge of the
union Oh British other British now
iris we definitely see ourselves as
Irish Scottish I am English the
political dynamics of today strain the
ties that bind the United Kingdom
[Music]
see myself as well I'm I'm trying to be
British
this election will in many ways define
the direction of the UK I've taken a
trip to the four corners of the kingdom
to measure hopeless it's come to the end
[Music]
[Music]
they were watching a t-rex tribute act
in Glenn Rafa's fight this month when
the real thing was a big thing in the
70s elections were different Scottish
independence once a fringe act is now
center stage this was a trip to gauge
the fragility of the Union from the
pollsters and the people my name is
Peter DAF I'm Krista McLean and I
identify as Scottish and British and I
identify as scottish imported delhi and
we have Sky News sway myself as I don't
see myself as being any different to
people here any other sort of
nationality why independence because I
think we could make as a nation I think
we've got enough guts and I think we're
going off for two children
grexit has stirred the Scottish
independence tepee north of the border
and so it's always been my view that if
the Union comes to an end it will come
to an end because of either English and
deference or hostility I think at the
moment there's probably more
indifference and hostility but there's
little doubt that there is a brand of
English nationalism which is abroad
which in a sense is not really
interested on whether Scotland continues
in the Union or not support for Scottish
independence has grown in recent months
we dropped in on the wild swimmers of
Loch Ness to see how the prospect of a
breakaway is going down I'm Marvin
britches I'm talking like you identify
my soul the Scottish the only way I can
stay in Europe is by leaving the UK then
I would rather stay in Europe no concern
you if the United Kingdom broke up no
concern at all this is our ma in
Northern Ireland north of the border
even if the sights and sounds speak of
the south
[Music]
[Applause]
hurling is Islands national game and
attracts are largely nationalist crowd
here one that loops southward in its
sport as it does in self-identity
over three years of brexit negotiations
talk of a hard border between north and
south didn't sit well here aim ranked a
PLA that famous a physician who singer
serves as more terraces people don't
rule from us my name's Brian McAvoy my
name is Lisa feeling my name is Damien
McCullough
identify as an Irish nationalist are you
British any sense do I have to answer
not a chance James oh I'm Irish pride of
it you identify as being Irish can't
split the country up and tell people
what they are amethyst shouldn't be I
think we're not has started to say Irish
national in Scottish nationalism start
to take even a stronger voice and take a
stronger man that their what we had
before and I do think the long-term
future of the United Kingdom has been
dragged as the one thing that has put
that in most in danger I remember a
hundred years ago we were separated so
maybe the way Abraxas gone that's coming
back to bite the English
[Music]
people in Northern Ireland have enjoyed
two decades unhindered by the troubles
that's not to say past history isn't
carried into the present politics still
turn on religious differences along the
upper Newton are drawed in East Belfast
past the wedding beyond the murals into
the suburb of Bala hackamore it's an
area predominantly Protestant albeit not
a political pigeonhole my name is Paul
Murphy I am Allison McClanahan I
self-identify as being Northern Irish I
want to be European my name is Amna
Garvey and I'm proud to be British
that's a culture I identify with and
love more than my own culture and that's
actually the culture I want to be part
of I don't want to be part of and the
Prime Minister is no Prime Minister we
were always told that people in England
didn't care about Northern Ireland and I
think the finger by brexit is that
that's that's proven to be the case and
he's trying to sell us down the river
why do you why do you say that she won't
know united Ireland and we don't want
that he's going to have riots on his
phantom he doesn't watch himself
Cathedral Quarter unsurprisingly
the brexit is having very differing
effects amongst people's views of Irish
unity so those who are in favour of
Irish unity are increasingly likely to
think it's going to happen and that they
want it to happen those who are opposed
to Irish unity or a wary of it are
increasingly resistant to it and it's
that polarization and the sort of
reinforcement of difference that we're
beginning to see through Bragg suits
that would be quite worrying I think for
the longer-term peace process that
pessimism plays out here at unionist
meetings in the East Belfast
constitutional club they've aired their
anger at Boris Johnson's brexit plan for
a customs border down the Irish Sea
mania Mesmer homes and a identify as
British the talk in here is ominously of
protest
as soon as you lie the threat of van
republicanism to achieve political again
you do run this risk of tensions being
heightened extreme sensitivities and
these public these public protests and
rejection can lead to other things and I
would first and foremost condemn that I
wouldn't want to say that we don't want
to see that happen but there is a risk
[Music]
back across the Irish Sea I headed to
Canaveral and Wales
in this bilingual time the Carnarvon
mill voice choir recently celebrated its
fiftieth anniversary
[Music]
the faces have changed over the years so
has the outlook a new cafe tanning jobs
to God he'll come raw tan only wearing
quality interpreting your habit don't
give him a shake he better as brakes
have made you feel less British yes it's
splitters I mean in the sense I
understand instance know how Scots feel
and I feel like you know if Scott
Scotland leaves the UK old I would feel
like a little brother who sees his big
brother leave the leave the Patriarca
home and make his own way in the world I
would be glad for him but I'd be sad to
me my next destination was England the
power house behind the breakfast room
before we hear the English voices let's
look at the views expressed in a YouGov
Paul for Sky News we voters across
Britain were asked if Scottish
independence was a price worth paying
for brexit 41% said yes asked if
Scotland becoming independent would be a
positive thing anyway 17% said yes we
voters were asked if a united Ireland
would be a price worth paying for brexit
25% said yes asked of Northern Ireland
joining the Republic would be a positive
thing anyway 17% said yes and leave
voters were asked if Welsh independence
would be a price worth paying for
leaving the EU 28% said yes
asked if wills becoming independent
would be a positive thing anyway 10%
said yes the English perspective on the
relevance of the Union is pivotal if the
biggest and most powerful partner in the
UK decides it doesn't have a future the
UK doesn't have one
as our poll reflects English nationalism
will be a factor in this election I
think the truth is that there's a set of
voters who want England's interest
protected right and if for them that
means leaving the EU then if that had to
be the end of the Union they would go
along with that that doesn't mean there
the union they wanted to break up but if
that's what it came down to that's what
they would prioritize all in 140 was ya
gone did you know that oXXO had bought a
new cube for brexit do you know what
it's called what laughing stock they
like a lot for the bingo and Belper
Derbyshire I went here to get a public
take on the political debates around
English interests I would say I am
English I feel we're a bit hard on - we
got where the nation that's it can't be
who we say we are we don't we have to be
British I don't see it's very fair
that's Scotland gets a Wales get to be
Scottish and Welsh but we can't be
English I think that happens a lot in
society at the minute the West Midlands
saw the highest brexit vote in Britain
how did they see Britain itself here in
Warsaw sixty seven point nine percent of
people turned their back on the Union
with Europe what do they care here for
the Union closer to home I'm Dudley
Swain I'm a member of the United Kingdom
I'm Claire identify his English I'm
English but I still do not see myself as
a member of the UK if leaving the EU
meant the breakup of the United Kingdom
how would you feel about that
I think NATO we need to break up and go
it's been walking around for two years
now and we just need to go but men the
breakup of the United Kingdom so be it
I'm not happy that UK's should break up
I think Wales and England the Scotland
and Northern Ireland are a great
integrals unit but we've got such
friction from Scotland my inclination is
that the next government ought to go to
Scotland and say we've got an agreement
you should leave us in 12 months time we
can save a lot of money you can be
independent see how it gets on
of course there is as they say only one
pole that cuts the country will speak
with a collective voice on December the
12th that will be the definitive verdict
on the state we're in and on the states
of the union